the rel
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video all
right my friends in this video i will
show you what one of house of the
dragons lead actors has said about the
new show
matt smith also known as daemon
targaryen finally revealed some of his
own thoughts about working on house of
the dragon
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again he also revealed some
interesting information about his very
own dragon karaxis let me show you what
was said on winterscoming.net because
that's where i saw this interview first
it says former doctor who star matt
smith appeared on the happy sad confused
show the other day and revealed some
information about house of the dragon
hbo's upcoming game of thrones series
matt smith will be daemon targaryen a
violent lustful character who loves
making war and covets the iron throne
occupied by his brother king viserys
targaryen
as matt says on the show daemon is an
interesting and dark and disturbed
character he will be sort of like house
of the dragons version of jaime
lannister
there are no men like me
only me
some fans might see him as a hero
whereas other fans will see him as a
villain
you're embarking on a huge new adventure
the the thrones universe was came
calling yes was this a yeah is this a
no-brainer of a thing when it comes
around it's just too good a thing to
pass up like what was enticing about
this one when this started to be talked
about
and dark and disturbed
part to play i think and i thought oh
you know it'd be interesting to try on a
broadway as well more than that
and uh you know flying some dragons and
get involved in some sword fights
that's only one of the reasons why matt
smith was interested in working on the
show he also said and i thought oh you
know it'd be interesting to wear one of
those blonde wigs and fly on the dragons
and get involved in some sword fights
well his character daemon will certainly
see his fair share of dragons and sword
fighting as i have said before daemon
will be involved in arguably one of the
greatest battle scenes in all of a song
of ice and fire the lake rushed up with
terrible speed then daemon targaryen who
had never fastened his riding chains
stood in his saddle
he leapt from his dragon to aemons and
in his hand was dark sister the valyrian
sword of aegon's sister queen vicenia
as eamonn one eye looked up in terror
daemon ripped off his nephew's helm and
drove the sword down into his one
remaining eye so hard the point came out
the back of the young prince's throat
half a heartbeat later the dragons
struck the lake sending up a gout of
water so high that it was said to have
been as tall as harrenhal's great tower
the lake boiled with dragon blood
and then was still
according to george rr martin himself we
will see well over a dozen dragons in
house of the dragon in daemon's dragon
karaxis will have a major role in this
series matt smith goes on to say karaxis
is pretty good you know he's big and red
and angry he's a really angry dragon
mine's the angriest of all the dragons
there is no angrier dragon than karaxis
he's a really moody bastard yeah how are
the dragons treating you that's how yeah
you know
yeah karaxis is pretty good you know
he's big and red and angry
i mean that's that's the way you like
your dragons right yes he's a really
angry dragon mine's mine's the angriest
mine's yeah i mean mine's the angriest
of all the dragons there is no angrier
dragon than grassy's he's a real moody
bastard
look you don't want if you're gonna have
a dragon you don't want the sedate chill
dragon you want the badass dragon
it's sort of like my dog
you want it with a bit of pep and
personality don't
you know
is that is there i would imagine on a
set like like this there are two ways to
feel like an immense pressure because
you're succeeding game of thrones or no
pressure because you know everybody is
going to be there and and ready to
receive you is it is it a little bit of
column and column b or like what's
what's the attitude of being in
something of this scale
it's definitely both josh yeah because
obviously you know
it's impossible
for
this show to ever really
succeed in the way thrones did thrones
became a sort of cultural phenomenon
for many people um
and you know it's it's never ever gonna
quite scale those heights in the same
way because that was its own unique
thing
um you know whether people are ready to
receive it or not who knows you never
know but we we you know we sort of make
it in earnest and we and we uh
try our best to deliver something that
is you know an entertaining world with
dragons and sword fights
and a hell of a cast too i might add
oh great cast
now when discussing the success of house
of the dragon matt smith had to say this
it's impossible for the show to ever
really succeed in the way that game of
thrones did game of thrones became a
sort of cultural phenomenon for many
fans and it's never going to quite scale
those heights in the same way because
that was its own unique thing well i
definitely agree with him there no
matter how good house of the dragon is
it likely won't ever reach the same
heights that game of thrones did simply
because something like game of thrones
was never done before
now i do believe house of the dragon
will be another major hit for hbo
considering they have brought in all of
those same ingredients that work so well
on game of thrones matt smith said he
would finish filming his scenes in
january so if you were expecting the
show to release in that month you will
have to wait a little longer until house
of the dragon airs on hbo max as i've
said before i believe we will see the
first episode somewhere around april
which falls in line with the release of
6 of the 8 seasons of game of thrones
then again we shall see
if you like staying up to date on any
and all information regarding house of
the dragon make sure you subscribe and
hit that notification bell that way you
will be notified whenever i release a
new video hopefully i will see all of
you back here for my next one as always
i want to thank everyone for watching
this video i hope you all have a great
day i will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you